JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
I'm from England,
as you can probably tell.
I'm from a small city
called Carlisle in England
from a small district
called Harraby
in Carlisle, in England.
This is one of the pubs.
AUDIENCE: All right!
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
As you can see they
thought long and hard
about the name of
the pub in Harraby.
The regulars of
this pub-- they call
themselves the "Pirates
of the Harrabian."
And every time-- I
really like that.
For my money that's the best
pirate pun I have ever heard,
and whenever I tell people
it, they are underwhelmed.
But you are all wrong.
That is clever and funny.
So we've come a long
way, haven't we,
since the '90s-- 20 years ago.
You have some friends
over and it's going great,
and then maybe two
of your friends
will start having-- oh, we
do have sound, excellent.
We start having a
disagreement about something
meaningless like the release
date of "Ghostbusters."
But then that argument starts to
get heated, and neither of them
are backing down.
But it's OK.
You hold aloft the answer.
For you are the proud owner
of Microsoft Cinemania.
Don't know why that disappeared.
Let's try that again.
Wee!
That's probably a
good sign that we're
going to have massive
graphical problems
during this presentation.
That's excellent.
We'll see if that continues.
But it's supposed to
give you instant access
to the history of cinema, but of
course, it's not truly instant,
is it?
Because first you must go to
the room with the computer in,
and then you turn it on.
And clunk, all the
fans start whirring.
You get the static buzz as the
CRT monitor whirs into action.
Windows 3.1 slowly boots up.
And then eventually
you get your desktop.
But then it does this.
[OLD WINDOWS STARTUP SOUND]
And that really sets your
expectations, doesn't it?
Because we are in an era
where booting up successfully
is a fanfare worthy moment.
[LAUGHTER]
But by the power of multimedia,
you reveal authoritatively,
that "Ghostbusters"
came out in 1994,
and you did that in
under 10 minutes.
The dinner party is saved.
[OLD WINDOWS STARTUP SOUND]
The web really
changed everything.
With the web, you get the
information instantly.
No installation is needed,
and an app such as Cinemania
[INAUDIBLE], they looked up a
date really, really quickly.
Having a separate app for
these things just became weird.
Suddenly the
internet was better.
It was built with this
new interconnected modern
world in mind.
And the browser runtime started
to replace more apps-- email
clients one of the first.
But then things like office
tooling, video players,
code editors even.
Native apps became
the exception.
If you look on the Amazon
top selling laptops list,
you'll see Chromebooks
there, and that's
how secondary native apps are.
Although that's not
true is it on mobile.
There, native apps
rule, because they're
built for the strengths of the
platform, and a lot of the web
predates that.
Some of the web is
even hostile to mobile.
Here's a creative agency
that I will not name,
but this is what
you get when you
visit their site on a phone.
"Choosing your
creative agency isn't
like buying a pair of shoes.
So why don't you make yourself
comfy and visit our site
on a real screen."
[GROANING]
But, they're right.
No, they're right.
Choosing a creative agency is
not like buying a pair of shoes
because I have never
had a shoe tell
me to fuck off and come
back when I have real feet.
[LAUGHTER]
If you visit their desktop
site, obviously you
get a much better experience.
You see the sites they've done.
They list the things
they're expert in, which
of course includes
responsive sites.
[LAUGHTER]
This is hostile to the
whole mobile platform.
The more worrying
case is sites that
are simply hostile
for the mobile web.
This is a horrible situation.
The user has gone into
these sites in a browser,
potentially following
a deep link.
And rather than sending
them to the thing
they want, we send
them somewhere else.
Where they can download
a thing, install
that thing, which they can run.
Which may contain the
thing they originally
wanted somewhere
deep within the UI.
Every day.
But no one's saying
that's a good experience.
No one is saying that's
good, but it's one
that many developers
think is worth it.
To get their users off the web
and into a native platform.
And why is that?
Well have a think
about the native apps
that you use day-to-day.
Those are the places
that the web has failed.
But what caused that failure?
What features do those
apps have that you
use that make them impossible
to replicate on the web?
For me, it's these apps really.
I use these often, or I
rely on them in some way,
and they can't be
done on the web,
because things like
push notifications.
This is vital for
these apps in yellow.
They tell me someone
sent me something
even when the app's closed,
or something happened.
I rarely often trip
it-- very rarely.
But I forget it's there,
but then occasionally it'll
send me a message saying oh,
your flight's been delayed.
Your flight's been cancelled.
That's really,
really useful to me.
Background sync of course--
the apps in yellow again.
They send and receive stuff
when the app isn't open.
From downloading podcasts to
sending that email later when
I have a better connection.
Which takes us to
the offline stuff.
I depend on this for more apps
than I realize-- way more.
From playing music, to
checking where my hotel is,
to looking up a
meeting location.
I don't want to depend on
connectivity for those things.
And of course, we need
better performance
and better operating system
integration, app menu icons,
battery stats, payment
and account integration.
Everything that makes it
first class on the platform.
The web can't do these
things, and that's a bug.
But what gives me optimism
is bugs that we are fixing.
We are actively landing
code to fix these things.
These are the ones I
want to talk about today.
These are quite something new.
Background sync happens
in the background.
Push notifications
are received and dealt
with in the background.
Offline isn't in the background,
but it requires something
to run sooner than
the page appears,
so it can handle network
connections and version control
and things.
And that thing is
a service worker.
This is the spec.
This moment got a round
of applause at Google I/O.
[DELAYED APPLAUSE]
Yeah, don't patronize me.
Fair enough.
I admit I could have dressed
this up a little bit.
I really like what graphics
cards do in this scenario,
because they're essentially
just circuit boards.
They don't do
anything on their own,
but they want to sell
themselves to gamers.
It's the thing they
absolutely must have.
So the boxes they
come in are amazing.
They're filled with this kind of
subdeviant art-- shite artwork.
You get the usual
terrible, sexist stuff
that you get with anything
to do with games it seems
at the moment, but also
things like the hideous
offspring of Yoda and
Shrek as found in one box.
And, of course, "Teenage
Mutant Ninja Dog"
appears on one of them as well.
So in that vain, I present
to you "The ServiceWorker!"
That's the [INAUDIBLE]
of the living using
his powers of evil to
control browser features.
What badge?
I thought about doing that, but
I really couldn't be bothered.
I'm sorry.
But you've got the skull and
crossbones on some slides,
right?
I did that in the airport.
[INAUDIBLE] jet lag.
If anyone wants to design
a better logo, please do.
But this is a feature that's
being worked on between Google,
Mozilla, Samsung, and
other third parties.
It's like a shared worker that
is shared between many apps,
and it has many pages even
and it has no thumb access.
Unlike a shared worker, it
can exist without any pages,
and it shuts down
when it isn't in use
keeping the memory
footprint small.
It gives us this background
JavaScript context
to do all of this stuff.
This is still in development.
So if want to play with
ServiceWorker today,
you'll need to use Chrome
Canary or Firefox Nightly.
And in Chrome you'll need
to About Flags and Enable
Experimental Web
Platform Features.
And once you've
done that, you'll
need to give the
browser a restart.
If Chrome isn't your thing,
then use Firefox Nightly.
Just go to About
Config, and you'll
need to enable
com.serviceworkers.enable,
and once again give
the browser a restart.
I'm going to stick to
Canary for the demos,
because we're here
in the Google office,
so it'd be rude not to, really.
But also the debugging tools
there are further ahead.
Firefox is going
to make-- they're
going to catch up
very, very soon,
but not quite at the moment.
So if you want to know
what's supported and where,
this site has answers--
is ServiceWorker ready?
It'll tell you the status of
all of the various subfeatures
of ServiceWorker
across the browsers.
So let's take a look
at the offline stuff
because it's the foundation
for the other features.
Offline suffers from
the same misconceptions
as progressive enhancement.
People say I don't need
my app to work offline,
because my users have permanent
internet connectivity.
But it's not just about
dealing with zero connectivity.
It's about treating the
network as an enhancement.
Elliot covered some
of this stuff before,
but when the user enters your
URL and navigates your site,
this creates a new document.
But we have to
get data for that.
So off we go to the network.
And this can take a long
time just to get the HTML
and, once we've got
that we can't render.
We need to send off
request for all the
subresources-- the CSS,
the JavaScript, the images.
And as these come back
we can start to render,
but not completely.
Because these start
other subresources.
XHR, forms, images
used by the CSS.
And then we can get
to a complete render.
That can take a
really long time.
As a practical
example, I'm going
to take this demo app
called "Trained to Thrill."
A simple responsive site that
displays latest train photos
from Flickr.
Don't ask me why trains.
I was on a train when
I started building this
and I had a moment of
complete zero inspiration,
but it's going to be trains.
Let's load it on a phone.
Now, we're going to load it with
a simulated edge connection,
and that's 250 kilobits.
So not the best
connection in the world,
but 15-year-old me
would have killed you
for that kind of connectivity.
It's by no means the worst that
you would get on a phone today.
So let's load it.
Three, two, one, go.
There we go.
We got first render
up after over a second
that wasn't
JavaScript dependent.
We get some content
after five seconds,
and then begins the long wait.
These images-- 200k each.
As we were saying,
if you're dealing
with a device of this
density-- images are big,
and this is what
Flickr would give me
if I wanted enough pixels
for a device like this.
We get our first image
after over 30 seconds,
and eventually after
what seems like an age,
we'll start to get the final
image for the top there,
and there it goes.
I have to cut that video down.
That's not real time--
it just takes so long.
Those figures are
the real figures.
Of course we could probably
compress those images a bit,
and we could do
something to ensure
that the top images
load a bit sooner.
I just took what Flickr gave me.
But we are still winning
compared to native
to this point, because the
equivalent to the native app
is a trip to the app store.
The download, the install-- it's
a slow and comparatively slow
user experience.
But native kicks our
ass in the second visit.
Because it used the
initial download
to cache a load of stuff,
and set a load of things up.
We have the browser
cache, but the whole web
is fighting for that cache,
and something pointless
can override something
really useful.
And we deploy stuff
really regularly.
So we make one
change to our CSS,
and now we have to change
the file name of the CSS,
because we
consolidated the cache.
But this page does
something different.
It registers for a
ServiceWorker allowing
it to do something
about that second load.
This registration happens
just with a single line
of JavaScript like that, giving
you a location for the script.
You can also scope it to an area
of your origin, which is useful
if you have one origin with
many apps such as GitHub pages.
The default is the whole
origin which we'll use here.
Registering its main
sync operation so
it returns a promise.
So you get call backs depending
on whether it succeeded or not.
You can only register for
ServiceWorker on pages
securely-- HTTPS.
ServiceWorker gives you so much
control that we cannot afford
to let that lie in the hands
of a man in the middle.
GitHub pages serve over HTTPS--
great place to put demos,
and local host is exempt
for development purposes.
As for this worker
script, we're just
going to put in a console log.
We're also [? going to listen ?]
for the install event,
and that's called when
the ServiceWorker sees
this worker for the first time.
So let's see that in action.
First I'm going to go to
ServiceWorker internals, which
is where our debugging stuff
is living at the moment.
It will move into DevTools,
but it's early days.
These are all the ServiceWorker
that the browser is aware of.
As you can see,
it's aware of none.
So let's open the
train site, and we'll
open DevTools there as well.
As you see down here, we've
had a successful smiley
face-- successful
ServiceWorker registration.
As we go to ServiceWorker
internals now-- ah,
there it is!
And that's our console messages.
Even better we can
open an actual DevTools
window for that worker.
We can run stuff on the console.
We can set breakpoints.
We can inspect things in detail.
If we fast forward time a bit,
this worker will terminate.
That's not a bug.
It closes when it's
not being used,
and that's just to save memory.
At this point, congratulations.
You are now wielding the
power of the ServiceWorker.
Well, what did it
actually get us?
Nothing.
Nothing at all.
But wait, that's
actually a good thing.
Trust me, it's great
that it does nothing.
Compare this to AppCache.
If we give an HTML page
a manifest, that manifest
contains nothing except
the words "cache manifest"
which is required
to make it valid.
Yeah, sure, I'd
expect my page to go
from this to this said
no one in the world ever.
AppCache missed the point of
the extensible web completely.
Almost as much as Disney did
with "Jake and the Neverland
Pirates."
A good pirate never takes
another person's property.
Shit pirates-- [MUMBLING]
Anyway, we didn't want to
repeat AppCache's mistakes.
ServiceWorker
doesn't do anything
unless you tell it
to do something.
AppCache broke a load of eggs
and failed to make an omelette,
but it is made of the
right ingredients.
There's routing.
We've got fetching, caching,
updating and version control.
But in order to
get them, you must
reverse the piles of
implicit behavior.
Which are of course guarded
by the army of robot wasps.
If you've used
that cache before,
you'll know exactly
what I'm on about.
So we got rid of all that.
We cleared it away.
We separated them out.
We give you the
separate parts to use
however you want
without getting stung.
This is the extensible web.
Don't let the platform
give you a fish, say, hey,
I want the fishing rod,
and show me how to use it.
But give me the fish as well.
This is what we want
from the platform.
We want high level
and low level APIs.
So first up-- routing.
Putting you in
control of requests.
The ServiceWorker
is event driven.
We've already seen it installed,
but there's also fetch.
And this is fine for
any navigation request
to your scope, but also
any subresources requested
by those pages.
So in ServiceWorker
internal, you're
going to start up this
ServiceWorker and inspect it.
And now I'm going
to navigate-- you
can see we've got the
[INAUDIBLE] event here
with the debugger statement.
And I'm going to
navigate to the page,
and as soon as we do that we hit
this debug point for the root
page.
And if we fast forward
a bit-- skip past
that-- we'll get another
request this time for the CSS.
And then we get
one for the logo,
and then one for the JavaScript.
And then we get one for the
request to Flickr's API.
This is to another origin, but
we still get an event for it.
And then we'll start getting
the requests for the images
through.
And we don't just
get the URL either.
You can get detailed information
about the requests, which
is the header, the
mode, the referrer--
as much as we can safely give
you in terms of security.
But, hey, the cool bit is--
it's like other events,
such as click, touch
start, and key down.
You can prevent the default
and do something else.
You can respond
with something else.
Responses can be
created manually,
so there I'm just
creating a new response.
There's nothing to do.
We change the response
from this to this.
But the interesting thing
there is we delivered that
without going through
the network at all.
Making it the first offline demo
of the talk only halfway in.
But we can do better than that.
When the browser
discovers a ServiceWorker
for the first time, we'll get
it to make loads of requests
to the network, and get
loads of responses back.
This may be fast,
it may be slow.
The network is unpredictable.
We don't care, because the
user already has the page.
We're not disrupting them.
If all the responses
come back successfully,
we'll throw them into the cache.
This precaching pattern
is good for stuff
that a native
equivalent would make
part of the initial
download, but we
get to do it in the background
without disrupting the user.
For our train site, this is
like the root page template,
the CSS for
JavaScript, the design
images-- all the static stuff.
And in the future when
we get a request for one
of these things-- eh,
if it's in the cache,
we'll just get in from
the cache and send it on.
The uncertainty of the network
is no longer our problem,
and this is really simple
thanks to the caching API
that comes through
ServiceWorker.
Giving you full programmatic
control over the cache.
So in terms of our train site--
in the install event that we
had before, we're going
to call event.waitUntil.
And this lets you
pass in a promise,
allowing you to extend
the installation process
or indicate its failure.
So here we're just going to
create a cache, give it a name.
That gives us a cache
object, and we're
going to add a load of stuff to
it-- all of our static assets.
This is an atomic operation.
If any of these fail,
the whole thing fails.
It fails the installation,
and the service worker
won't control pages.
That means if install succeeds,
then we have these files.
We can rely on having
them as a dependency.
Here to tell us
a little bit more
about Chrome's implementation
of the cache API,
we're going to go live to
Senator Vreenak of the Romulan
Empire.
Senator, how's it looking?
SENATOR VREENAK: It's a fake!
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
Thank you very much, Senator.
Tell the kids I said hi.
The API that's in Canary at
the moment is a complete fake.
It doesn't really
work at all yet.
It's not usable.
But frankly there is a
polyfill backed by IndexedDB.
The proper implementation
will arrive in a few weeks.
But how do we use
these cached items?
So we can call caches.match
as part of a respond call,
and we can pass in a request.
And that will look into
caches for the response that
matches the request.
And matching is done
very similar to how
it works in a normal
browser cache.
Things that method,
URL, vary headers.
If there's no match,
you'll get null back,
which is going to
start breaking things.
But promises let you
recover from that.
[INAUDIBLE] and if
responses is faulty,
we can do something else.
What can we do instead?
We could return something
else from the cache
like a fallback page, but what
if we want to try the network?
To do this we need
to be able to make
a request using JavaScript.
So back in the '90s--
in 1999 to be exact--
Microsoft engineers were
working on an exciting new API,
but they didn't know
what to call it.
It contained some
initialisms-- some acronyms--
and they couldn't
decide if they should
be all caps like
HTML and inner HTML,
or just the first letter
like the element by ID.
So they did both, and XML
Http Request was born.
[LAUGHTER]
Other than that,
the name is perfect.
XML because it only deals
with XML-- except it doesn't.
Http because it's restricted
to Http-- except it isn't.
And Request because you
get a request object back--
except you don't.
We tried to modernize this API
a bit so it makes more sense,
but it's still pretty bad.
Especially since JSON is
still absolutely terrible.
We've been patching this
API up for 15 years.
I do not want to be
using this API when
it is old enough to drink.
Thankfully the fetch.spec by
Anne van Kesteren of Mozilla
gives us lower level control
over requests and responses.
We've already seen some parts
of it-- the request object,
the response object--
that part of this.
Lower level APIs tend to be more
complicated and harder to use.
But XHR is so bad,
that is not true here.
The equivalent to
this in the Fetch
spec-- fetch(url)
gives you a promise.
Has it in the form what you
want, gives you a promise,
and you're done.
This is a forward
thinking API as well,
so ES6 arrow functions
make it a lot neater.
ES7 async functions-- you
could turn it into a one liner
if you want.
It's a bit messy,
but it is possible.
So to answer the
question, how do we
send this request
to the network?
Fetch it.
So where does that go?
So [INAUDIBLE] before,
three, two, one, go.
It renders almost instantly.
We get some data in
after two seconds.
That's still coming
from the network,
but our JavaScript
arrives so much quicker
that we were able to
make the request sooner.
Still a tad slow with
the images though,
but we got the first
render really quickly.
All of that stuff Elliot
was talking about.
All of that DNS
and network crap.
We didn't have to
worry about it.
We got to first render
without all of that.
But with these images--
let's fix those.
When does a request for
a Flickr image-- that
goes through the ServiceWorker
as all requests do.
And if you've got it in a
cache, we'll just return it.
Otherwise, off we
go to the network.
The long round trip.
And once we get a response back,
we'll send it to two places.
We'll send it to the cache
and the page at the same time.
So next time it's
requested, we can get it
straight from the cache.
We're doing this
with Flickr images.
It's also good for avatars and
things-- that kind of pattern
In terms of code, we
do this by special
casing a URL ending
in static flickr.com,
and that's where the
Flickr images live.
And in that case, we're
going get it from the cache
if it's there.
Otherwise we do a fetch,
add it to our cache,
and send it back to the browser.
We have to be careful
with this pattern
though, because we're adding
to the cache with every request
for a Flickr image.
So we'll need to garden
that cache at some point.
We'll pick that up later,
but for now how does actually
improve things?
Three, two, one, go.
Instant render as
before, we get content up
in a couple of seconds.
But this time we've
got some images.
All the things
we've already seen.
Not this top one-- we
haven't seen that one before.
That arrived in
about 11 seconds.
This is pretty good,
but we're still
dependent on the
network for that API
call to Flickr-- the
one that tells us
which images to display.
Let's fix that.
This one's a little
bit different.
The page makes
effects request, which
goes by the ServiceWorker,
as as requests do.
At the same time, the page also
goes straight to the cache,
because pages connect
to the cache as well.
And if it finds a
response, it'll take it.
It'll render using that result,
and that will be old data.
And that will trigger the
download of all the images,
but they're in
the cache as well.
We'll get to our first
few really quickly.
Meanwhile, the ServiceWorker
sends a request to the network,
gets it back, and does what we
did with the Flickr images--
it sends it to the page and
the cache at the same time.
This is also a good point for
us to clean up the image cache.
With this pattern, the
page makes two requests
and renders content twice.
Once from the cache, and
then from the network.
This means we get to
render faster full content,
but provide up to date content
when we get it, if we get it,
which you wouldn't if
the user's offline.
The best native apps do this.
Not many, but the best ones do.
So here's where we're at.
With special casing
static Flickr,
we also want to special
case api.flickr.com.
In that case, we do this.
I'm not going to go
through it line-by-line.
At the top there, we're fetching
and putting in the cache.
At the bottom we're
returning to the browser.
This gnarly bit in
the middle is where
I'm going through the
caches, finding out
which images we don't need
anymore by the response we've
got from Flickr
and deleting those.
Even with promises this is
a bit ugly, but frankly ES7
async functions make
it really small.
And that's how
ServiceWorker started.
This pattern requires the page
to make two requests, though.
So over on that side we make
two requests-- one for the cache
and one for the network,
and we race them.
Because it is possible for
the network to beat the cache.
We see this a lot
in Windows machines.
Windows machines with
virus scanners installed.
Well, probably-- you
buy a PC these days,
it comes with eight
virus scanners installed.
And that basically just
wrecks disk access times.
So the network can be
faster a lot of times.
If the cache succeeds and
then the network succeeds,
we just swap in the data.
If the cache succeeds but
then the network fails,
we silently fail at that point.
That's a good
offline experience.
This is what apps
like Twitter do.
That's probably too much
code to show on slides,
I understand that.
But my point is we're expressing
relatively complex async custom
behaviors in relatively
small amounts of code.
Even using the low
level primitives.
And the effect of that--
let's remind ourselves
where we started.
On the first visit
without ServiceWorker,
it took us ages to
get to first render,
and ages to get any
content-- there it goes.
And then the images
just took far too long.
Over a minute for all of them.
But with the
ServiceWorker and the code
that we've shown in the slides
and the caching-- three,
two, one, go.
And it's an instant
render with content.
New content comes in
a little bit later,
and now image will come
through in a few seconds.
[APPLAUSE]
But we shaved a second
off first render.
We shaved over 30
seconds for some images.
This is the kind of
stuff that Elliot
would kill for to be able
to do that on the network.
But we can do that
without the network.
And you get those
kind of response times
whether you're on a fast
connection, slow connection,
or no connection.
This is what catches us up
with native style performance,
and it gives us the foundation
for these other things
like push notifications
and background sync.
These haven't arrived in Canary
yet, but they're coming soon.
I guess I'm slightly
running out of time,
but I'm going to-- before we
look at the code for push,
I'm going to try
and do a live demo
and we'll see how that works.
OK, we're going to
do the [INAUDIBLE].
Yay, it worked this time.
Excellent.
OK, so what I'm
going to show here
is a build of Chrome
that we have internally.
So there we go.
Chromium.
So this is just a
simple chat application,
and we'll see if this
works if the demo
gods are shining upon me.
So I'm going to type in hello.
[INAUDIBLE]
So see if that
arrives on the phone.
Come on-- yes, there we go.
OK.
That's nothing special, right?
WebSockets have been
able to do that for ages.
So what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to close the app.
So that's it.
There's no apps running
at all on this phone.
The browser is not running.
But I'm going to
send another message,
and what happens this time is
just using open web standards--
and there is actually
a spec for this--
we've received a
push notification.
A native push notification.
And because it's native, it
has also appeared on my watch.
There it is as well.
Just using the
open web entirely.
As I said, this isn't a
custom built at the moment,
but we're hoping to ship
this stuff in Canary very,
very soon.
So the code for that
is pretty simple.
So on your page, you
register for push.
You get some
registration details,
which will give you
the details for GCM--
for Chrome-- the
Cloud Messaging stuff.
Firefox will have
their own thing.
Apple will have their own thing.
And you'll send out to your
server once you've got it,
and that gives you the means
to send messages to that user
later even if their browser's
closed and the site's closed.
They will have to grant
permission for this.
We're not going to
give you this for free.
You'll get some kind
of notification saying
are you happy with the site
doing background stuff.
But then when the user
receives a push message over
in the ServiceWorker,
you get an event for it.
You can look at the
data that you get.
In our case, we'll
update some caches
and then show a notification.
But you can really-- you
can do what you want.
You'll also get an event when
the notification's clicked.
Once again you can do what
you want at this point,
but it's likely that
you're going to open a URL.
You can also focus an
existing tab as well.
I'm running out of
time, so I'm going
to skip through some of
the background sync stuff.
But it's very similar
to push messaging stuff.
Like if sending an email fails--
say that [INAUDIBLE] database,
register for a
background sync saying,
hey, sometime in
the future give me
a chance to do something else.
And in your ServiceWorker you'll
get an event-- sync event.
Look at the ID, and
do what you want,
which is usually going to be
send-- send those emails that
failed to send.
You can also-- this is
registering for a single sync
event, which is kind
of like I wasn't
able to do some stuff
due to connectivity.
Let me do it later when
the user has connectivity.
You can also request an
interval sync as well,
an interval you
specify as a minimum.
Things will actually
happen heuristically
depending on how often
the user uses the site,
and we'll try and coalesce with
other events to save battery.
With ServiceWorker,
we gain a lot
of the features that
make native superior,
but we retain the bits
that make the web superior.
Instant on, no install
required, open platform.
Chrome is going to start
shipping this stuff to stable
this year.
The offline stuff especially.
And then next year for some of
the push and background sync
stuff.
Firefox is actively
developing it as well.
Microsoft are investigating it.
We haven't heard
anything from Apple,
but that's not
unusual at this point.
Thankfully it's design to
be used as an enhancement.
It won't disrupt the browsers
that don't support it.
So as long as you use
basic object detection,
as soon as it hits the millions
of users that have Chrome,
you can start giving
them that benefit.
ServiceWorker doesn't
make stuff work offline.
It doesn't send push
messages into cache updates
and notifications.
It gives you nothing for
free, but it treats you
like an adult.
It gives you the
moving parts and says
do what you want with them.
Use it to make things faster.
Make things work offline.
Use it to transcode
a video format
the browser doesn't
support natively.
Build a client side wiki.
We've seen that already.
Do what you want.
Do it in a way that's
unique to your app.
The way that gives the
best user experience.
I am heavily biased
because I've been involved
in the design of
this stuff, but I
think this changes
the scope of what
the web is capable of more
than any feature since XHR.
Let's build some
cool stuff with it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you, Jake.